una repetición de lo que vimos en síria
así define amnistía internacional la
invasión rusa de ucrania en su último
informe sobre la situación de los
derechos humanos en el mundo la
organización acusó a moscú de crímenes
de guerra
amnistía internacional ha documentado
ataques indiscriminados y muy
probablemente deliberados contra civiles
los corredores humanitarios no funcionan
y la gente que intenta usarlos puede
quedar atrapada la situación es o está
muy cerca de ser de posibles crímenes de
guerra
en su informe la organización pide
reformas dado que las instituciones
multilaterales como el consejo de
seguridad de la onu no han podido evitar
conflictos globales que propiciaron la
invasión rusa de ucrania
francamente hablamos de un consejo de
inseguridad el consejo de seguridad no
ha sido capaz de resolver los conflictos
del mianmar etiopía o israel allanando
el camino para la insolencia de rusia
para su agresión
con respecto a la gestión del
coronavirus en 2021 amnistía habla de
una historia de traición e hipocresía
los países ricos prometieron igualdad de
acceso a la vacuna pero mientras los
índices de vacunación en europa superan
el 70 por ciento algunos estados de
rentas bajas no han recibido ni una
dosis
2021 es la mayor traición al pueblo
recuerden en los primeros meses vamos a
reconstruir mejor e hicieron todo lo
contrario pusieron los beneficios de
unas pocas empresas por encima de las
personas entre niveles sin precedentes
de migración en 2021 la ong lamentó las
violaciones de derechos generalizadas y
el aumento de los discursos xenófobos en
el norte global aunque aplaudió el
aumento de la solidaridad por parte de
la sociedad civil con los desplazan